this video is kindly sponsored by
fabulous the number one self-care app to
help you build better habits and achieve
your goals hey 42 here they say you
should never bring a knife to a gunfight
and as far as i'm concerned that's sound
advice in fact i'd probably just
recommend politely declining the
invitation altogether if you can get
away with that without coming across as
rude
another man who lived by this never
bring a knife to a gunfight mantra was
jack churchill or mad jack churchill to
his friends
why mad
just keep watching
now like most of us i constantly give
myself a hard time on a daily basis
about my diet and water intake so i've
decided to enlist the help of fabulous
to help improve my daily routine and
stay healthy fabulous makes it easy for
anyone to develop and stick to healthy
habits thanks to science-backed daily
routines and as a result it makes you
feel healthier fulfilled and more
productive fabulous is great because
it's 100 personalized and there are two
ways you can use it the guided way or
like i'm doing self-guided where you
choose habits from hundreds of options
and fabulous helps to embed those chosen
good habits into your life through
behavioral science principles timely
reminders and science-backed content and
unlike other self-development apps
fabulous is gentler more rewarding fun
and offers a more supportive approach
which i found works really well for me
fabulous has had an amazingly positive
impact on my life in such a short period
of time as well and i know it can do the
same for you start building your ideal
daily routine the first 500 people who
click on the link will get 25
off fabulous premium
anyway jack took part in a great many
gunfights in his life including the
biggest gunfight of them all the second
world war
and whilst he didn't command with a
knife what he brought instead wasn't
much better because
mad jack churchill
went to fight the panzer driving machine
gun toting nazis with a broadsword and a
long bow
you might be assuming from this unusual
choice of armament that churchill was
some kind of british ninja metal gear
soldiering the nazis to death with
silent but deadly weapons
and that would make sense
except i haven't told you about the
other weapon jack churchill chose to
bring along to his many gunfights
his trusty bagpipes
now i'll be the first to admit that i'm
not up to speed on the latest ninja
trends but i'm fairly sure bagpipes
aren't considered part of the standard
kit not even in scotland
the funny thing is despite his
shall we say
eccentric choice of armament
mad jack churchill was a truly brilliant
soldier with a war record that's passed
into legend
some of the things he did during the
second world war and beyond are so
remarkable it's hard to believe they
really happened
what they did so without further ado
this is the story of mad jack churchill
the greatest badass in the history of
the british army
jack churchill was born in british
ceylon which is today sri lanka but
during his childhood he also spent time
in hong kong
england and on the isle of man where he
was educated at the fancy pants king
williams college
the world-renowned royal military
academy at sandhurst was next before
jack got his first army posting in what
was then burma and is now myanmar at the
age of 20.
not all that much is known about his
military exploits in burma but he
certainly seems to have enjoyed his time
off during which he explored much of the
indian subcontinent from the back of his
prized zenith motorbike and found time
to master both the bagpipes and archery
as one does after 10 years in burma
churchill decided life was a bit too
slow for his liking and so he resigned
in search of other entertainment
he took a job as a newspaper editor in
nairobi kenya and explored his more
sensitive side working as a male model
and even had a brush with hollywood
acting as an extra in both the thief of
baghdad and a yanket oxford
in 1938 he took some time out to beat a
whole lot of scotsman to second place in
a prestigious bagpiping competition
i bet that made him popular and the
following year he represented britain
during the 1939 archery world
championships in oslo let's just say he
was one of those utter bastards who's
good at everything he does
but jack's days of leisure were coming
to an end when britain and france
declared war on nazi germany in 1939
jack churchill found himself amongst
close to 400 000 british soldiers sent
to france as part of what was known as
the british expeditionary force
to begin with things were quiet in
france too quiet at least as far as jack
was concerned he was so bored he
actually volunteered to go and join up
with the finnish army who were busy
trying not to get murdered by stalin
soviets at the time
jack was all set to go as well and had
fate not intervened he might just have
found himself fighting alongside another
legendary soldier i covered on this
channel recently simo haiha also known
as the white death the greatest sniper
in history
but it was around this time that
swastika-shaped started to hit the
fan in france and so the finland trip
was cancelled as the british
expeditionary force beat a hasty retreat
towards dunkirk
whilst the allies were no maps for
hitler's blitzkrieg tactics at least not
at the time men like mad jack churchill
made sure the enemy paid dearly for
every allied life they took
and it was in doing exactly that that
jack churchill first made a name for
himself
he and his men were holed up in a small
village called le epenet when a lookout
spotted a large german patrol heading
straight for them so what do you think
mad jack churchill did when faced with a
superior force in the middle of what was
fast becoming enemy territory did he
order a silent retreat before the men
were spotted did he call for
reinforcements
did he take cover and wait for the enemy
to pass
did he bollocks he sent instructions to
his men to prepare an ambush
telling them to take up firing positions
focusing on the road that entered the
village
churchill himself would give a signal
when it was time to start shooting
as for what exactly that signal was
mad jack was crouching in the upper
window of a tower when the germans
entered the village
with his men hidden out of sight
jack waited until the very last moment
then calmly stood
raised his weapon and fired at the man
leading the german column hitting him
full on in the chest
not with his machine gun mind you
with a longbow
so far as anyone knows this was the only
longboat kill of the second world war
and the last bow and arrow killed by a
british soldier in history can you
imagine what must have gone through the
german soldier's mind as a giant arrow
suddenly appeared in their sergeant's
chest
yeah me neither
they didn't have much time to take it in
anyway because churchill's men rightly
assumed this was their signal and opened
fire from all sides
in the meantime jack had ditched the bow
and sprinted towards the tower where
raising his favorite broadsword high
above his head he bellowed a war cry and
charged into the enemy flag
why exactly mad jack churchill decided
to fight world war ii with medieval
technology is honestly kind of unknown
though he did take pleasure in telling
his men that any officer who goes into
action without his sword is improperly
dressed
as for whether he was just extremely
eccentric morbidly fascinated with the
more visceral ways of dealing death or
just a few sandwiches short of a picnic
your guess is as good as mine the ambush
worked brilliantly but even mad jack
couldn't keep the germans hide at bay
for very long and eventually he and his
men along with over 300 thousand others
made it to dunkirk and from there to
england as part of the legendary
operation dynamo the biggest military
evacuation in history
and it was back in blighty that mad jack
got wind of a new elite raiding and
reconnaissance force that had just been
formed under direct orders from his
namesake british prime minister winston
churchill himself in case you've been
wondering the two weren't related not
that the germans knew that as we're
about to find out
this new force known as the commandos
would carry out raids behind enemy lines
disrupt plans and supply chains and just
generally cause utter chaos
as far as mad jack churchill was
concerned it sounded perfect
as an added bonus training for the
commandos would take place in scotland
land of jack's second favorite thing in
the world after killing people the
bagpipes
he signed up in a heartbeat
after about a year of training jack was
ready for his first mission the rather
wonderfully named operation archery
the target was the norwegian island of
vogssoy a german-held center of fish oil
production
fish oil might not sound like the
highest priority target in the middle of
a war but this stuff wasn't used to
grease the joints of old age pensioners
it was a key ingredient in the
manufacture of explosives
by targeting these stores the allies
would not only hamper the german war
machines bomb production they'd also
draw hitler's attention away from the
far more important eastern front
as you've probably gathered already mad
jack churchill was a man who liked to
lead from the front which is why he
placed himself in the very first landing
craft heading towards the island
most men who know they're about to be
running headlung into a hail of machine
gun fire are quite understandably a
little bit nervous
i'd go so far as to say that unplanned
pant wetting would be a perfectly
acceptable way to spend those last few
moments
but not mad jack
instead of both literally and
figuratively himself as any
normal human being would have done
jack stood defiantly facing the shore
back ramrod straight and eyes on the
prize
then he unfurled his backpipes took a
deep full breath and blasted out an
inspiring tune with all the force he
could find in his
when the landing craft hit the shore
jack was the first man on the beach
slinging his bagpipes over his shoulders
he raised his broadsword high in the air
bellowed and now trademark war cry and
headed towards the german position under
heavy fire lobbing grenades as he went
needless to say the germans didn't know
what had hit them and the island was
captured within hours operation archery
was a resounding success the commandos
lost 17 men but took 120 defenders with
them along with a further 98 prisoners
considering they were the ones storming
the defended position
those numbers are incredible
even more importantly in the aftermath
of the raid hitler diverted 30 000
troops away from the eastern front to
norway spreading his forces even thinner
two years later mad jack found himself
in italy after the allies strategic use
of a corpse drawing operation mincemeat
paved the way for the invasion of sicily
i did a whole video on that crazy story
a little while ago if you're interested
in sicily jack led a string of
devastating raids ambushes and
counter-attacks completely disrupting
german plans in the process in what
might just have been his most famous act
of the entire war well after longbowing
a man to death obviously
jack and the single corporal under his
command captured an entire german
observation post on their own
jack's plan of attack was pretty
straightforward he simply snuck up on
the isolated sentries and introduced
them all to his broadsword
the two men managed to capture the post
and take 42 prisoners on their own
without firing a single bullet
the next stop on jack's war world tour
was yugoslavia where the commandos were
busy harassing german forces stationed
along the dalmatian coast
but it was here that mad jack's mad luck
finally ran out
in what was probably the most dangerous
mission of his entire career jack led
one of three forces attempting to
capture the german-held island of brac
part of what is now croatia
[Music]
churchill's unit was to storm a key
strategic hilltop on the island where
the germans were well dug in behind
minefields and barbed wires
under cover of darkness churchill and
his men started up the hill towards the
enemy
well i say
undercover of darkness
any element of surprise was probably
somewhat undermined by the fact that
churchill himself led the charge playing
his bagpipes at maximum volume
the german position was indeed overrun
but it came at a huge cost
only six commandos including jack made
it to the top of the hill
and there were still plenty of germans
left when they got there
the situation was pretty bleak
jack and his men had hardly any ammo
left between them and with incoming fire
raining down from all sides they were
being picked off
one by one before long jack was the only
man left alive and uninjured
he knew there was no chance of escape
and no way of taking out all the german
soldiers before the inevitable arrival
of a bullet with his name on it and so
in a scene so incredible it's hard to
believe it really happened jack
laid down his car by
with enemy soldiers closing in grenades
blowing up all around him and mortar
shell explosions inching ever nearer to
his position
mad jack churchill picked up his
bagpipes once more and as loudly as he
could played will ye not come back again
as death came for him
it was a mortar round that got him in
the end
the aftermath of the explosion all the
quieter because jack's piping finally
had
ceased but mad jack churchill's story
doesn't end quite yet it was going to
take more than a mere mortar shell to
keep him out of the war the blast had
knocked him out cold but soon enough he
was coming round
unfortunately he woke up to find himself
surrounded by enemy soldiers
and that was very bad news indeed
because it meant he was at the mercy of
something called the commando order
you see the newly formed commandos had
given hitler so much trouble that he'd
decreed any of their number who were
captured should be shot on site and
without a trial
dazed from the mortar blast and relieved
of his weapons by pipes included it
seemed jack's position was entirely
hopeless he was surrounded by men with
orders to end his life no questions
asked
so
how did he get out of this one
well for once it had nothing to do with
bravery and broadswords
in fact it was a stroke of pure luck
that kept him alive his name
the germans were well aware that several
of winston churchill's relatives were in
active service in the british army at
the time and in mad jack churchill they
mistakenly believed they'd gotten their
hands on the british prime minister's
nephew
as a result jack was taken to germany
and a concentration camp called
saxonhasen
like all concentration camps it was a
truly horrific place
all told 200 000 men women and children
were brought to the camp during the
course of the war
only half of them made it out again
from the moment mad jack arrived there
was only one thing on his mind getting
the hell out of there and as luck would
have it he soon met several like-minded
individuals who happen to know a thing
or two about mounting a successful
escape
bertram james harry day sydney dowse and
johnny dodge
the artful dodger to his friends
those names might not mean anything to
you but i'm pretty sure you'll be
familiar with their story because those
men were all survivors of arguably the
most famous breakout in history
the mass escape from stalag luftfree
better known as the great escape
sachin housing concentration camp was no
match for this bunch of expert escape
artists and together they tunneled under
a wall and disappeared into the
countryside
it was a fairly precarious form of
freedom though sachin hauser was just
north of berlin in the middle of enemy
territory
jack figured his best chance was to head
for the coast some hundred miles away
and along with bertram james he almost
made it by hitching rides on passing
freight trains and hiking for the german
countryside
but the men were recaptured just miles
from the coast near the city of rostock
another stint in a concentration camp
followed this time in dachau before
churchill and a hundred or so other
high-profile prisoners were sent south
to austria
the war was almost over at this point
and security was beginning to slip so
jack was able to escape the germans once
again by simply walking off when the
power at his camera failed
another long journey lay ahead of him
this time south into italy he hiked
alone for the brenner pass
and a hundred miles later bumped into an
american patrol near verona he was saved
jack spent the next few years seeking
out military action wherever he could
find it he first got himself sent back
to burma in hopes of fighting the
japanese in the south pacific
but by the time he arrives nuclear
devastation had been unleashed on
hiroshima and nagasaki and the war was
officially over
jack retrained as a parachutist at the
age of 40 and was posted to british
palestine where he once again excelled
in his own unique way
at one point attempting to defend a
medical convoy from a huge ambush with
just 12 men
and later helping to evacuate 700 people
from a hospital in jerusalem
but jack did finally accept that touring
the world in search of wars to fight in
was more of a young man's game because
eventually he stopped trying to kill
people and took a desk job not that he
ever lost his trademark eccentric streak
it's said he used to startle passengers
during his commute home on the train by
standing up and suddenly flinging his
briefcase out of the nearest window
it wasn't quite long bowing a man to
death but it wasn't far off by london
commuter train standards
jack had his reasons though it turned
out the train went right past his house
and he was simply throwing the briefcase
into his garden to save himself the
trouble of carrying it home
he remained a bit of a thrill-seeker too
even in his senior years whilst working
as an instructor at the land-air warfare
school in australia jack took up surfing
a hobby that would become a lifelong
passion
in 1955 just shy of his 50th birthday
mad jack churchill became the first man
to surf the river 7 tidal ball on a
surfboard he designed and built himself
today thousands of enthusiasts follow in
his footsteps every year
considering he was an absolute maniac
who laughed in the face of danger well
bagpiped it's pretty remarkable that mad
jack churchill made it to old age at all
but make it to old age he did
jack passed away in 1996 at the grand
old age of 89
gone but most certainly not forgotten
[Music]
thanks for watching
you